hi Florian what do you need today a
pullover or a t-shirt a t-shirt okay
let's have a look good choosing a new
t-shirt without having to worry about
the price is quite a relief for Florian
and his mother Nadine itea is a charity
devoted to helping children in need it
provides secondhand clothing free of
charge
Nadine rarely has enough money to buy
her son new clothes she's a single
parent and works part-time her wage plus
social welfare payments add up to about
twelve hundred euros a month Lukesh
often we did go on outings and go on
holiday once a year but by the end of
the month money is tight so a new toy or
an outing often has to wait a week Volkl
a Tartar Florian can also do his
homework eat lunch or learn to swim all
for free it's a welcoming place for a
number of kids here in northern Berlin
almost a quarter of people living in the
German capital are considered poor
that's among the highest rates of
poverty in Germany
[Music]
nettie be daft it's woeful more and more
people are turning to arta need is
growing because the state is doing less
and less this development has been very
clear in recent years sometimes Nadine
only gets by with help from her parents
even though she has a professional
qualification and a job but she's not
one to complain karasuno then of course
it would be nice if I earned more in my
job I don't only go to work for the
money but to be a role model for my
child no Liam good here at Archer they
never want the kids to feel that they're
poor still it's the children who suffer
the most when their families don't have
enough to make ends meet